tobias jetzt hat man gedacht mit boris
becker der hat die schlimme zeit
überstanden also insolvenz
steuerprobleme scheidungen und jetzt das
jetzt dieser termin irgendwie gefüllt
aus dem blauen heraus wie kam es dazu ja
das muss sich wahrscheinlich
ich möchte nicht in seiner haut stecken
das muss sich wahrscheinlich anfühlen
wie so ein bumerang es kam dazu weil die
britische insolvenz behörde ihm vorwirft
nicht vollumfänglich in seinem verfahren
mit mit den behörden zusammenzuarbeiten
und er soll gegen insgesamt 19 insolvenz
auflagen verstoßen
das bedeutet er hat einfach sachen nicht
richtig angegeben nicht richtig
ausgefüllten formular das wird man im
vorjahr im britischen insolvenzrecht ist
es so wenn man da ein fenster
insolvenzverfahren gibt kann das nach
einem jahr abgeschlossen werden
das muss da dazu muss man aber so sagt
die behörde mit ihnen komplett und
transparenz zusammenarbeiten und das
wirft man ihm vor dass er das getan hat
und jetzt stehen da diese sieben jahre
haft
plötzlich im raum das ist ja offenbar
die höchststrafe wenn man sich den fall
jetzt so ein bisschen anschaut du hast
es getan
kommt es wirklich zu diesen sieben
jahren als urteil
also man wirft ihm unter anderem vor
dass er zum beispiel die existenz einer
wohnung in london nicht angegeben haben
soll oder zwei immobilien in deutschland
soll er auch verschwiegen haben dazu
beträchtliche summe an bargeld
aber es gilt die unschuldsvermutung dass
die sieben jahre sind wirklich das
höchstmaß und ob es dazu kommen wird
das bleibt abzuwarten wenn der prozess
der nächstes jahr beginnt es bleibt also
spannend um boris beckers bleibt eine
schwierige zeit für ihn
du wirst den fall und natürlich auch das
verfahren nächstes jahr weiter begleiten
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren